Se você compra gluta achando que é
sempre superior ao Nak, talvez esteja só
pagando mais caro por um resultado pior.
Um estudo publicado na revista Redox
Biology comparou diretamente essas duas
substâncias em pessoas com síndrome
metabólica e o resultado surpreendeu até
os pesquisadores. Em 21 dias de
acompanhamento, a gluta oral comum não
conseguiu aumentar significativamente os
níveis de gluta no sangue. Nakc. Sim,
esse funcionou. E aqui está o detalhe
que a maioria dos vendedores de
suplemento não te conta. A forma como
você toma faz toda a diferença entre
jogar dinheiro fora e realmente proteger
as suas células.
Deixa eu explicar porque que isso
acontece. Agrotationa é o antioxidante
mestre do seu corpo. Cada célula depende
dela para neutralizar radicais livres,
eliminar toxinas e manter as
mitocôndrias funcionando. O problema é
que quando você engole um comprimido de
gluta o seu sistema digestório quebra
essa molécula em pedaços antes que ela
chegue ao sangue. É como comprar um
carro desmontado esperando que ele ande
sozinho. A biodisponibilidade da
glutatona oral convencional é tão baixa
que muitos estudos simplesmente não
conseguem detectar aumento nos níveis
sanguíneos após suplementação. O NAC
funciona de forma completamente
diferente. Ele é um precursor da
glotationa. Quando você toma nacisteína
que ele precisa para fabricar a
glotationa dentro das próprias células.
É como entregar os tijolos para o
pedreiro construir a parede em vez de
tentar enfiar uma parede pronta pela
porta. A biodisponibilidade do naque
oral fica entre 6 a 10%, o que parece
pouco, mas é suficiente para fornecer o
substrato que as suas células precisam.
Agora, presta atenção nisso. O estudo da
Redox Biology, conduzido por Smith e
colaboradores testou três abordagens
diferentes em 20 voluntários durante
três semanas. No grupo que tomou gluta
oral convencional, os níveis de gluta no
plasma praticamente não mudaram. No
grupo que tomou na houve aumento
mensurável, mas o resultado mais
interessante veio do terceiro grupo que
usou glutation sublingual. Essa forma
que é absorvida diretamente pela mucosa
da boca superou tanto a grotation oral
quanto o NAC em termos de elevar os
níveis plasmáticos e melhorar marcadores
de estresse oxidativo. E quando falamos
de velocidade de resposta, que é o que
interessa para quem quer resultado
rápido, o NAC leva vantagem sobre a
gluta oral. Em estudos clínicos, o NAC
começa a elevar os níveis de glutationa
em questão de dias. Efeitos mais
pronunciados aparecem entre uma e duas
semanas de uso. Agrotaation oral, por
outro lado, pode levar semanas para
mostrar qual que é efeito, se é que
mostra. Mas aqui entra um dado que mudou
minha forma de recomendar esses
suplementos. Pesquisadores da Bayor
College of Medicine, liderados pelo Dr.
Rajago Paul Secar, descobriram algo
fascinante. O NAC sozinho não é a
estratégia ideal. Eles desenvolveram uma
combinação chamada Glinac, que junta
glicina com NACE na proporção de um para
um. Em um ensaio clínico de 24 semanas
publicado no Clinical and Translational
Medicine, idosos que tomaram Glinac
tiveram aumento de 200% nos níveis de
gluta não foi um erro de gitação, 200%.
Além disso, os marcadores inflamatórios
despencaram a etiucina 6 caiu 78% e o
TNF alfa caiu 57%.
A produção de ATP mitocondria aumentou
83% e o dano oxidativo ao DNA reduziu em
até 73%. Mas por que então a glicina faz
tanta diferença? Porque a gluta é um
tripeptídeo formado por três
aminoácidos: glutamato, cisteína e
glicina.
O nac fornece a cisteína, que é
geralmente o fator limitante, mas
conforme nós envelhecemos, os níveis de
glicina também caem. Quando você fornece
os dois precursores juntos, o corpo
consegue fabricar gotationa de uma forma
muito mais eficiente. Então vamos ao
protocolo prático. Se você quer
resultado rápido, está com orçamento
limitado, na escolha mais custa efetiva.
A dose padrão nos estudos varia de 600 a
100 mg por dia, divididos em duas ou
três tomadas. Para a maioria das
pessoas, 600 mg duas vezes ao dia é um
bom ponto de partida. Tome com estômago
vazio ou com uma refeição leve, porque
os alimentos muito gordurosos podem
reduzir a absorção. Se você quer
otimizar o máximo, considere a
combinação Glinac. Os estudos usaram
doses que variaram de 2,4 a 7,2 g por
dia de combinação numa proporção de um
para um entre glicina e naque. Uma
abordagem intermediária seria 1,2 g de
glicina mais 1,2 g de naque por dia. E a
glicina, por sinal, é um aminoácido
barato, com sabor levemente adocicado,
que você pode misturar em água ou no seu
shake. E a gluta quando é que ela faz
sentido? Se você vai investir em
glotationa, escolha as formas com melhor
absorção, seja ou lipossomal.
Agrotaationona sublingual mostrou
resultados superiores no estudo que eu
mencionei, porque ela é absorvida
diretamente pela mucosa bucal, evitando
a degradação do trato digestório. A
gluta lipossomal, ela usa pequenas
esferas de gordura para proteger a
molécula durante a digestão. Ambas
custam mais caro que o NAC, mas entregam
o que prometem. Uma coisa importante,
não adianta tomar o suplemento certo se
você continuar esgotando a sua gluta por
outros lados, por exemplo, álcool,
tilenol, paracetamol em excesso,
exposição a poluentes, estresse crônico
e falta de sono vampiros de gluta como
tentar encher uma banheira com ralo
aberto. Também vale mencionar que o NAC
tem benefícios adicionais que vão além
da gluta ele tem ação muolítica,
ajudando a afinar o muco das vias
respiratórias. Ele é um antídoto padrão
para intoxicação paracetamol e estudos
recentes, incluindo ensaios clínicos em
pacientes com COVID-19 publicados na
revista Nutrients em 2023 mostraram que
o NAC intravenoso ou endovenoso melhorou
a oxigenação e reduziu marcadores
inflamatórios em pacientes críticos.
Então para resumir de forma bem direta,
em s dias de uso você provavelmente vai
notar mais diferença com nac do que com
gluta oral convencional. Se quiser
turbinar o resultado, adicione glicina
na proporção um para um. E se o
orçamento permitir, a glotationa
sublingual ou lipossomal oferece a
entrega mais direta do antioxidante
mestre. Mas lembre-se, a estratégia mais
poderosa é fornecer os precursores e
deixar o seu próprio corpo fabricar a
glutationa onde ela realmente é
necessária que seja dentro das células.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial, porque eu vou te
contar uma verdade conveniente. O
YouTube e o conselho de medicina me
limitam. Aqui eu preciso simplificar,
censurar dosagens e omitir protocolos
controversos. Sobre nac glutationa, por
exemplo, eu não posso falar abertamente
sobre as dosagens terapêuticas mais
altas que eu uso em caso de estresse
oxidativo severo, intoxicação hepática
ou condições autoimunes. Na comunidade
fechada não existe esse filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica, incluindo o
protocolo completo de Glinac com
dosagens precisas, combinações com
outros antioxidantes como alfa, lipoico
e selênio e os marcadores laboratoriais
que eu monitoro para ajustar o
tratamento. Casos de reversão que
parecem possíveis, combinações de off
label que funcionam e fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso ao meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários. Nós
temos lives semanais respondendo
perguntas, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer a visão funcional real sem
simplificação para as massas, clique em
seja membro. Não é para curioso, é para
quem quer resultados. Agora, se você
quer ir ainda mais fundo, existe o nível
dois. A cada duas semanas nós fazemos
lives de imersão total com 2 horas de
duração desse artigos linha por linha
como os estudos do Tor Seca sobre Glinac
e envelhecimento que a maioria dos
médicos ainda não conhece. Debatendo
controvérsias que ninguém ousou tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Então,
não é só sobre aprender, é sobre
pertencer ao ciclo interno de quem está
mudando o jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem.
Você tem,
e já que estamos falando de defesa
celular e mitocôndrias, você precisa
conhecer a combinação de co enzima Q10
com PQQ. Esses dois compostos trabalham
em sinergia para potencializar a energia
celular, especialmente para quem tem
mais de 40 anos. Assiste esse vídeo aqui
que vai complementar perfeitamente o que
você aprendeu hoje. Agradecimentos
especiais aos nossos queridos membros
dos estudos avançados da comunidade
fechada do YouTube. Estrigo, Juliana
Pontes e Ana Medicina, Antônio Renato,
Karim, Lourdet, Carlos Rovi, Odonor
Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis Oliveira,
Adriane BMS, Jorge Cabral, Marcelo
Pimentel, Cláudia Leitão, Alex Caldas,
Ana Paula Vascular, José Fortunato
Mutinho, FS Machado RJ, Souljo Cioli,
Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela
Mar Silva Elô Terapias Integrativas e
Saúde Lã.